The female lion lion is dissatisfied. She has recently added the election
For the post of king using the first vote after the mark
Even though its kingdom began as a sound democracy with many parties and candidates for the post of monarch
They quickly descended into a two-party system and the citizens ended up not liking any candidates but being restricted
In this system because of the problem named spoiler effect
But, one of the subjects of the Queen from a distant land claims and my father has a solution and he
Alternative sound. what is the difference?
Let's see that we will follow one of the voters on Election Day, the Red Squirrel. Under the two systems
There are five candidates to win the post of king of two major Gorilla parties
And three other candidates, the tortoise, the owl and the tiger.
In the first system after the mark, the red squirrel gets a form that selects only one candidate
The red squirrel loves the turtle candidate and even helped in his campaign but knows that
That his new neighbor the gray squirrel will vote for the gorilla
And what about the rest of the animals? Red squirrel thinks to himself, who to
Will they vote? The debates on the animal news network were not presented
The two big parties, the squirrel thinks it will be a close result of the gorilla
Cheetah while his position of the gorilla stand neutral but he
He fears the most fear of the cheetah, and that he can only choose one candidate
He gives his only voice to the gorilla in the hope that the leopard will not be allowed to rule
This is called a strategic vote and is a necessity under the first system after the mark
Now let's look at the alternative vote that the father of the red squirrel explains
Rather than choosing only one candidate who can rank them from their preferred candidate
For the least favored candidate enter the voting booth and get the
The form, but this time he chooses the turtle as his first choice, then choose the owl second and then
The third gorilla is hates the leopard and the tiger evenly stops
Fill in the form and place it in the box
At this point the squirrel does not care what exactly will happen to him
Other concerns go, but you dear citizen want to know how to count the votes
Let's see: while the Turtle is popular at some
Citizens receive only 5% of the vote and exit the race
And because citizens ranked candidates by popularity we can know what would have happened
If the tortoise did not enter the elections without the tortoise, voters would be like the red squirrel
They chose the owl instead of the tortoise and thus moved their voices to it as if the tortoise did not enter
In the election originally. That is why he sometimes claims alternative sound
The instant replay round, because it has the ability to simulate a set of elections by being excluded
The candidate is less popular after each tour without consuming time and cost
Which would have resulted from a series of campaigns, one by one.
The alternative sound method completes the exclusion of the less popular candidate until one of the candidates obtains
A majority (more than 50%) or one candidate
And because no one won a majority after the next candidate, the tiger, the tiger's voters were eliminated
Choose the cheetah as the second choice and the cheetah will get the sounds of the tiger
In the final round the gorillas are eliminated. Gorilla voters chose the owl as their second choice
The owl will receive these votes and win the majority and crown a king
The alternative sound system is better because it produces a better agreed winner
Number of voters. In the case of alternative sound, some defects are important
Be aware that all the flaws that it shares with the first mark after
Both are subject to fraud by dividing electoral areas and are not proportional systems. They do not guarantee a winner
In the manner of the French philosopher and sportsman Kondersie (which is something that math lovers hate but time can not explain here)
Over time both regimes are heading towards two major parties
However, the alternative sound has a major advantage lacking the first system after the mark
And this feature makes it superior to the athlete on the first after the mark: the absence of spoiler effect
Imagine elections by the two big parties, the gorilla and the leopard, and it seems to the leopard
That the victory is inevitable by 55% to 45% and then shows the candidate of the third party is the tiger
The tiger can convince 15% of the cheetah voters to support him and the result is as follows
Under the first system after the tag wins Gorilla although the majority did not want
To rule. Under the alternative sound and because all the voters of the tiger
They put the cheetah as their second choice, so the cheetah wins because a majority of citizens
The animal kingdom prefers the rule of leopard rather than gorilla
Using the alternative voice, citizens can support and grow small parties that agree with them without being concerned
From helping someone they do not like to win.
After understanding the differences between the two systems, the Queen declares that the alternative sound is
The rule of the king's election, and everyone is happy ... not everyone is right.
The two major parties can not afford to be self-sacrificing and must work hard in their next campaigns for votes
This was an alternative voice explanation by me CGP Gray.
Thank you very much for watching